[Music]
police used water cannon on these
protesters in the southern city of
siruvananthapuram on saturday
they were among thousands of people
around the country
who heeded farmers calls to join their
movement
many stopped traffic by sitting on roads
and at toll collection centers in the
states of jammu rajasthan haryana
punjab and telangana they said they
wanted to show their solidarity with
those who've been blocking the highways
around delhi
for more than two months
there are at least 80 places in punjab
where farmers groups are protesting and
blocking roads against narendra modi's
government and the farm laws
to force them to roll them back there is
a blockade here at the golden gate too
[Music]
fifty thousand police and paramilitary
personnel have been deployed in
and around the capital new delhi police
say they're taking extra precautions
since the outbreaks of violence between
police and protesters on
india's republic day january 26th
since republic day police have erected
many rows of barricades outside the
three major protest sites on delhi's
outskirts making them
very difficult to access water
electricity and internet services have
been
intermittently cut off at the sites
where hundreds of thousands of people
are camping out
the un's human rights office has asked
the indian government and protesters to
exercise maximum restraint
but also said the right to peaceful
assembly and expression should be
protected both
offline and online
the government has arrested more than
120 people in connection with the recent
violence
and charged farm union leaders with
writing and sedition
it's also had hundreds of twitter
accounts suspended
farmers say the government is treating
them like criminals
farmers are not that aggressive that
barbed wire has to be put up
the government shouldn't have done this
farmers are not from some foreign
country
they are people of the same country as
modi even a child doesn't behave the way
modi does
and he's a senior citizen they shouldn't
be resorting to such measures to stop
farmers
this is absolutely wrong farmers say
they are undeterred by the government's
crackdown
and will continue their protests until
the agriculture laws are repealed
elizabeth puranam al-jazeera gazipur
uttar pradesh